des évocations complètement spontanées
que les Français ont quand ils pensent à
des migrations sont toutes négatives il
y a quatre grands registres qui se
dessinent quand on essaye de prendre
leur parole de français ce qu'on appelle
des verbatim et des rangés dans des
grandes familles il y a un premier
registre qui est tout simplement qu'il y
a trop d'immigrés en France c'est net et
sans emballage c'est une idée assez
claire il y a un deuxième registre qui
est un peu plus nuancé qui est sur la
difficulté économique à accueillir tous
les accueillir des immigrés en France où
il y a des Français qui nous disent on
ne peut pas se permettre d'accueillir
tous les immigrés il y a un troisième
sujet qui émerge qui est lié à aux mots
maux qui serait attaché à la question de
l'immigration qui serait enfin liée au
sujet de l'immigration certains sites la
violence la délinquance etc et puis un
dernier registre qui est plus
protéiforme mais qui est en fait l'idée
que j'ai appelé moi le grand la peur du
grand déclassement plus que la peur du
grand remplacement le sentiment qu'en
fait les immigrés ont des droits et des
sons voilà bénéficie de certains avant
dont nous Français alors c'est comme ça
que le disent les gens qu'on interrogé
c'est pas moi qui le dit nous français
on n'y a pas le droit et pendant ce
temps là nos services publics se
dégradent notre hôpital se dégrade en
quelque sorte d'injustice au fond qui
ressort oui c'est ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant ça permet aussi d'apporter
un regard un peu décalé sur le sujet on
a toute une partie de la population
on y reviendra après on a une proportion
majoritaire de Français qui aujourd'hui
considère qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en
France mais ce qui est intéressant
d'être comprendre les ressorts de ce
sentiment et on n'est pas sur du ressort
strictement idéologique alors il y a
sans doute chez certains ce ressort là
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier un peu
schématiquement de de penser raciste
mais il y a surtout une motivation qui
est présente dans beaucoup de catégories
vous l'avez dit d'injustice de
déclassement le sentiment que quand on
est de la classe moyenne en France et
bien on doit à la fois travailler on
peut pas bénéficier des aides sociales
dont certains bénéficient et notamment
certaines populations immigrées et dans
le même temps on voit certains services
publics se dégrader dans leur qualité on
a moins accès à certaines choses et donc
un vrai sentiment effectivement
d'injustice voire même d'abandon de la
part de l'État on va revenir dans le
détail sur les résultats de ce sondage
que vous donnez dans votre note pour la
Fondation Jean Jaurès mais d'abord à
David
l'immigration est-ce que c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui en France qui est marqué
politiquement alors c'est un sujet qui
reste marqué politiquement
c'est un marqueur politique c'est un
marqueur politique qui est de moins qui
en est de moins en moins un je
m'explique on a une question qui est
vraiment une des questions clés de
l'enquête qui est diriez-vous
aujourd'hui qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en
France on a les deux tiers des Français
qui répondent oui à cette question
et alors ça des réponses qui sont
beaucoup plus marquées chez
sympathisants à droite ou elle
atteignent des scores proches de 8
français 8 personnes sur 10 mais c'est
une idée qui progresse aussi nettement à
gauche qu'on a près d'un sympathisant de
gauche sur deux 48% qui désormais
considèrent qu'il y a trop d'immigré en
France c'était c'est 20 points de plus
que qu'il n'y a donc on a une vraie
progression mais pour autant on a un
point qui reste vraiment une ligne de
clivage très net qui est le sentiment et
les perceptions de la façon dont sont
traités les immigrés et les migrants
notamment avec pour le coup des vraies
lignes de clivage donc voilà on a on a
un sujet qui reste marqué politiquement
mais de moins en moins clivant de
manière complètement structuelle alors
je le disais dans son discours télévisé
de lundi dernier Emmanuel Macron a fait
référence à l'immigration écoutez-le le
renforcerons aussi le contrôle de
l'immigration illégale tout en intégrant
mieux ce qui rejoignent notre pays
Emmanuel Macron qui dit donc vouloir
lutter contre l'immigration illégale il
veut son emparer en même temps vous
faites le constat dans votre note que
paradoxalement l'immigration ce n'est
pas un sujet qui est très présent dans
le débat public alors c'est un sujet qui
l'a été un petit peu au moment de la
campagne électorale de 2022 la campagne
présidentielle mais qu'il a été au tout
début de la campagne lorsque le premier
candidat a rentré en piste si tu peux
m'exprimer ainsi c'est s'emparer du
sujet je parle d'Éric Zemmour c'est un
sujet qui du coup était un petit peu
présent dans les débats du du Congrès
des républicains mais qui ensuite a été
occultée alors pour plein de raisons
notamment pour en raison de la guerre en
Ukraine on est passé sur d'autres sujets
et une campagne qui était très courte
souvenez-vous marquer notamment par la
question du pouvoir d'achat mais c'est
vrai que le sujet de l'immigration a été
assez peu présent d'ailleurs et les
enfin elle est assez peu on imaginait
qu'il allait avoir ce projet de loi qui
était la phase qui arrivait après à la
réforme des retraites et c'était sans
doute le moment Gérald Darmanin mais qui
semble un peu reporter au calendrier
pour le moment alors soit couper soit
découper reporter ce qui va revenir sur
le sur le devant de la scène ou pas je
ne sais pas mais du coup ce débat n'aura
pas lieu et d'ailleurs les Français dans
l'enquête le disent c'est un sujet dont
il est compliqué de parler en France
aujourd'hui qui reste un sujet sensible
oui Français sur 10 le pense et dans le
même temps on le sentiment qu'on ne
enfin n'ont pas le sentiment qu'on en
parle trop notamment dans les médias
donc sans doute qu'il y aurait de la
place pour un débat alors la difficulté
c'est d'avoir un débat apaisé sur un
sujet comme celui-ci et qu'on s'est
sensible et potentiellement hautement
inflammable mais effectivement les
Français déplorent que peut-être
aujourd'hui
sujet n'est pas toute la place qui
mériterait d'avoir mais en tout cas on
en parle d'un point de vue et je salue
ceux qui nous ont rejoints qui nous
regardent en direct notamment Nicole 06
Rico et claudius15 sur le Figaro.fr
Adélie suffit carpasique vous soulignez
dans votre note pour la Fondation Jean
Jaurès qu'à gauche quand on parle des
problèmes liés à l'immigration le
racisme arrive devant l'intégration
économique et sociale des réfugiés
oui ça c'est quelque chose qui est
marquant oui c'est quelque chose qui est
marquant et ça fait référence à la
question que vous posez précédemment sur
est-ce que c'est un sujet l'immigration
qui reste clivant
elle est de moins en moins il est de
moins en moins mais il est encore en
partie parce qu'effectivement à cette
question cette fois une question fermée
non pas une question ouverte qui est
quand vous pensez à l'immigration quels
sont les thématiques que vous associez à
l'immigration on voit que vraiment pour
le coup il y a un clivage très net entre
la gauche et la droite les sympathisants
de la droite vont d'abord évoquer des
thématiques comme l'insécurité et la
violence si tu es par près des un peu
plus des deux tiers des sympathisants
les républicains ou les sympathisants du
rassemblement national ils vont citer
aussi l'islamisme en deuxième position
là où le le la hiérarchie va être
complètement différente à gauche ces
sujets là insécurité islamiste loin
derrière et eux aussi en premier lieu
les conditions d'accueil des migrants et
la question du racisme donc il y a une
perception une en tout cas une
sensibilité au sujet qui n'est pas la
même pour autant encore une fois je l'ai
dit on a de plus en plus de
sympathisants de gauche qui estiment
qu'il y a trois immigrés en France et
voilà mais qui n'est pas forcément
paradoxal on peut avoir le sentiment
qu'être d'Ingré et pour autant souhaiter
que la question de l'accueil des
migrants soit faite dans des conditions
tout à fait acceptable et humaine alors
c'est vrai que les prises de parole à
gauche sur l'immigration ne sont pas
très nombreuses j'aimerais juste vous
faire écouter ce que déclarer Fabien
Rousset président du Parti communiste
français c'était il y a environ une
semaine franchement regardez ce qu'ils
ont fait de notre pays ces dernières
années ils ont mis la France sur
leboncoin ils ont signé des traités de
libre-échange à tour de bras ils ont
transformé nos frontières en passoire et
ouvert la France aux quatre vents au
marchand et à la finance et aujourd'hui
ils reviennent la bouche en cœur en nous
parlant de souveraineté souveraineté
souveraineté
non mais dis donc ils ont vendu le pays
c'est le grand déménagement industriel
Fabien Roussel le président du Parti
communiste Adélie Sophie kerpasique ces
propos de Fabien Roussel je voulais
qu'on les entende parce qu'ils ont fait
énormément réagir à gauche Fabien
Roussel il s'est fait énormément
critiquer pour avoir parlé de frontières
passoire pourquoi est-ce que ça suscite
tellement de réactions à gauche quand on
parle d'immigration parce que c'est un
peu un sujet tabou on ne veut pas en
parler alors c'est un sujet tabou alors
ça dépend de qui vous enfin de qui on
parle je pense que c'est un sujet qui
est compliqué pour pour les politiques
et en particulier par exemple les
parlementaires parce que mais il est
tabou pour pour des raisons qui sont que
ce c'est parlementaires ou ces
politiques ils ont face à eux un
électorat qui a changé sur le sujet et
qui est justement pétri de paradoxe
paradoxe et à la fois emprunt des
valeurs qui sont celles traditionnelles
de la gauche autour des schématise un
peu autour des questions d'humanisme
d'universalisme et donc cette notion de
la France est un pays une terre
d'accueil on doit accueillir tout le
monde et dans le même temps on un
électorat qui considère qu'il y a trop
d'immigré en France qui pose des
questions notamment socio-économiques
parce que certains électeurs eux-mêmes
se heurtent à des difficultés ont
sentiments qu'on accueille trop
d'immigrés et c'est cette difficulté à
concilier ce qui est aux yeux des
parlementaires ou des leaders politiques
de gauche constituent la colonne
vertébrale de la gauche avec ce que de
plus en plus de leurs électeurs disent
qui rend le sujet difficile à
appréhender et disons difficile à
traiter à mettre au cœur de débat donc
si je vous comprends bien pour la
plupart des cinq petites des
sympathisants de gauche en tout cas
parmi ceux que vous avez interrogé il y
a ce paradoxe entre eux il faut traiter
l'immigration c'est un sujet mais bon en
même temps on n'a pas trop envie de s'en
occuper c'est ça le paradoxe alors à mon
avis il est plus du côté des des leaders
politiques de la gauche je pense que les
sympathisants de gauche eux souhaitent
qu'on s'occupe du sujet
qu'on continue à être fidèle aux valeurs
d'humanité d'universalisme d'accueil
mais pour autant qu'on c'est cette
phrase de Michel Rocard que je que je ne
parle cité mais c'est vraiment cette
idée que on peut pas non plus accueillir
toute la misère du monde et qu'il faut
trouver le juste équilibre mais à mon
avis il y a plus un décalage aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être ça qui est problématique
à gauche un décalage entre les
perceptions des électeurs de gauche et
celle des représentants et des leaders
de la gauche qui considèrent que
que non il y a enfin voilà que non il y
a pas trop d'immigrés en France que
c'est pas un sujet qu'on a traité sous
le prismola et qu'il faut j'imagine bien
que si le projet de loi a été allé au
Parlement comme il devait aller
initialement on aurait eu des
parlementaires qui seraient montés vent
debout contre le projet de loi or quand
on teste les dispositions prévus dans le
projet de loi les unes après les autres
on voit bien qu'elle recueille la
sentiment non seulement d'une majorité
de Français mais pour la plupart d'entre
elles à l'exception d'une seule que l'on
a testé la sentiment aussi d'une
majorité alors plus ou moins forte de
sympathisants de la gauche donc il y a
surtout à mon sens un décalage entre le
la base électorale de la gauche et les
leaders de la gauche aujourd'hui à
délice suivi carpasique ce n'est pas la
première fois que vous vous penchez sur
l'immigration la perception des français
de l'immigration si on compare cette
étude avec vos études précédentes avec
des études présentes que vous avez fait
avec BVA est-ce que on observe un
durcissement des positions des Français
sur cette question clairement je vous ai
décidé tout à l'heure le chiffre de 69%
des Français qui considèrent qu'il y a
trop d'immigrés en France c'est 6 points
de plus qu'en 2018 donc une vraie
progression et une progression qui est
d'autant plus marquée chez les
sympathisants de la gauche et quand on
essaye de faire une espèce de typologie
alors un peu schématique mais des
différentes attitudes à l'égard de
l'immigration on peut distinguer trois
grandes catégories ce qu'on nous on a
appelé les ouverts ce sont les Français
qui considèrent que non il n'y a pas
trop d'immigrés en France et que par
ailleurs la France doit continuer
d'accueillir les migrants qui en font la
demande on a ce qu'on appelle les
réservés ceux qui disent il y a trop
d'immigrés mais bon ceux qui en font la
demande notamment pour des questions
politiques il faut continuer à les
accueillir et puis elle est réfractaires
qui sont il y a trop d'immigrés et il
faut arrêter les migrants on a observé
un glissement progressif avec un petit
peu moins d'ouvert qu'en 2018 une baisse
de 4 et un glissement vers les
réfractaires qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux on est à 34% des Français
aujourd'hui et qui considèrent qu'il y a
trop d'immigrations et qu'on ne peut
plus accueillir d'immigrés on était à
30% seulement en 2018 donc on est
souvent il y a un glissement une forme
de durcissement c'est-à-dire parmi
toutes les catégories que vous citez
toutes ces personnes estiment tout de
même qu'il faut prendre le sujet par le
corps si je veux comprendre bien oui
n'empêche pas l'autre c'est pas parce
qu'on considère qu'on considère qui est
trop d'immigrés ou considère qu'on puis
qu'on peut continuer à accueillir des
immigrés en tout cas les Français
considèrent dans leur majorité qu'il ne
faut pas mettre le sujet sur le tapis et
qu'il faut qu'il faut l'adresser alors
vous passez aussi en revue dans votre
note les différentes dispositions qui
pourraient être mises en place par le
gouvernement alors je dis pourrait parce
que pour le moment on ne sait pas ce qui
arrivera concrètement au Parlement si ça
arrive du moins un jour mais en tout cas
les mesures que le Gouvernement avait
annoncé vouloir mettre en oeuvre quelles
sont les mesures qui sont le plus
plaisir le plus plébiscité pardon par
les Français que vous avez interrogé
alors on a testé en tout huit mesures
parmi et celle qui était dans le projet
de loi initial il faut avoir en tête que
sur ces huit mesures il y en a sept qui
recueillent la sentiment l'adhésion de
plus de 7 Français sur 10 donc c'est
déjà pour vous dire qu'on est sur quel
que soit la mesure testée des taux
d'adhésion vraiment très élevés
puisqu'on est entre les trois quarts des
Français et 90% d'entre eux après il y a
deux mesures qui sont qui se détachent
encore plus du Lot si je puis dire avec
plus de avec environ 9 Français sur 10
qui adhèrent c'est le durcissement des
amandes à l'encontre des marchands de
sommeil qui est soutenu par 93% des
Français et là on a un soutien qui a
marqué à la fois à droite à la fois au
centre à la fois à gauche peut-être pour
des raisons d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas
complètement les mêmes dans un cas c'est
peut-être pour lutter contre une
immigration illégale et dans l'autre
pour préserver justement les conditions
d'accueil des migrants donc on a mais en
tout cas tout ce qu'on verse vers le
souhait de durcir les amandes à
l'encontre des marchands de sommeil tout
comme on a près de neuf Français sur 10
qui souhaitent qu'on augmente les
amendes à l'encontre des passeurs elle a
aussi avec un insentiment qui est marqué
à droite comme comme à gauche donc il y
a des mesures aujourd'hui qui font
consensus en tout cas ceux qui sont
soutenues par une majorité de Français
les amis ça vous avez interrogé je
voudrais reprendre la réaction de nous
78 sur Le Figaro.fr qui nous regardons
direct qui se demande si le durcissement
dont vous parlez tout à l'heure lors du
sissement des positions des Français sur
l'immigration ne serait pas lié à ce que
les Français voient dans la rue ce qui
constate l'effet divers qui jour après
jour s'affiche dans les journaux alors
de manière rationnelle objective j'ai
pas moins de enfin de mesurer en tout
cas c'est effectivement c'est ce que je
disais c'est il y a une part du ressenti
chez certains de nos concitoyens qui est
lié au sentiment que
immigration égale violence égale
délinquance donc voilà ça fait ça fait
partie des registres qui sont évoqués
spontanément par une partie des français
quand ils pensent migration donc
effectivement il y a un lien sans doute
entre ce que eux perçoivent à
l'extérieur et leur ressentiment à
l'égard de l'immigration une toute
dernière question d'aller se faire
basique sur ce sujet sur l'immigration
l'action du gouvernement aujourd'hui
elle est perçue comment par les Français
que vous avez interrogé elle est perçue
comme un suffisante mais c'est pas un
critère d'évaluation soit parce que
globalement aujourd'hui sur quasiment
l'ensemble des thématiques
testées qu'elles soient régaliennes ou
économique ou autre globalement le
gouvernement est critiqué et n'est pas
jugé à la hauteur donc voilà donc
effectivement on a seulement un tiers
des Français qui considèrent que
l'action du gouvernement est
efficace mais c'est globalement le petit
socle de soutien qui reste derrière
l'exécutif en ce moment les Français
sont oui sont critiques mais dans leur
ensemble en tout cas il y a que sur
l'immigration mais sur notre sujet
également et bien merci beaucoup en tout
cas
[Musique]